welcome to the iron Lord podcast episode
number 21 and we've been away a while
it's good to be back at the round table
we got the Lords in the building and we
have a very special guest that I'm
excited about and this is the Lord
that's been with us from the very
beginning you know during the destiny
only phase of the ILP you know this Lord
has given us tremendous support he is an
active founder of the playback gaming
network you can catch him then a lot of
our LP podcast there
he's also an art creator he's an avid
arc clamp and a good friend of mine
introduced to me through Lourdes attic
my man Lord Dizzy's in the building how
we doing Lord dizzy what's up man that
that thought that's very flattering very
funny it makes me feel good about myself
like I'm doing some I'm doing it for the
people absolutely it's a pleasure man
pleasure
real quick before I move on to the rest
of laws always wanted to ask Lord discus
how does the name dizzy frigidly I need
the backstory alright alright this this
is this is a very long my last name way
back in the day used to be it still is
obviously but my last name is Wayne and
a couple of friends they used to call me
Wayne head off of I don't know if you
remember the dough you know Wayne hit
and that's around the time where Snoop
Dogg was doing the whole shizzle for as
old as it went from there to Wayne dang
the wind is and it just like dropped off
the dish so for a while I was going by
diz and like even to this day somebody
will say there's an out you know I just
respond to it like I know who I know
what it is one of my good friends you
know he kind of like extended a little
bit more he would be the one to call me
dizzy and so that's just where dizzy
popped up and I original
yeah my original name was dis lanta I'm
done I have a I'm very connected with
the city of Atlanta even though I don't
live in you know today today right right
so it kind of like hyphenated is and
Atlanta you know that's where did Lana
came from well I've kind of felt like I
needed to make a name change and it's it
just came all together so that's where
uh did he kind of like so we kind of
like together that little conglomerate I
gotcha
I'm glad you shared that with the table
today's big that we're at absolutely man
of course we got the usual suspects at
the roundtable we have the soloist Lord
the Lord who appreciates nothing more
than the single-player experience no my
lord I've been how we doing sir doing
well sir just recovering for a few long
weeks a lot of work but finally getting
out from under it so hopefully get
someone game playing absolutely
absolutely and of course the access game
[Music]
nothing less than the premium experience
Lord King how we doing sir
I'm so happy that we're back I do
apologize for us being away for so long
I I do gotta say one thing though um
Mike Ibarra um I don't like you pushing
your agenda with combat sports I went
back and forth with you on this you
don't have to be a fan of USC and put
down boxing boxing numbers speak for
their self though the fighters getting
paid speaks for their self when you
start paying your fighters what they're
worth and you start packing arenas and
giving that money back to your fighters
then I think your sport is viable but
right now your sport is cool and it's
combat sport so you don't have to put
down one to pick up another the numbers
speak for itself
our numbers are
there's nobody walking away from box and
maybe you personally don't like boxing
that's cool
maybe you come when Floyd fights Conor
McGregor maybe you'll watch maybe you
can watch the sweet science and action
as your man get his head bashed in
understand exactly what goes on but this
forever is you saying that boxing people
are walking there's nobody walking will
you walk the way that's fine we fine
without you watching boxing is a nice
thing but you don't got to put down one
a big up another i watch UFC i watch
boxing I'm a fan of combat sports so you
don't have to exclude one to make your
shine you know you're dying on its own
and I'm so happy that the boxing and UFC
world is coming together what kind of
McGregor vs. Floyd Mayweather everybody
tune in and let those numbers show that
you know boxing is there in combat
sports is there alright so you don't got
to do that
Mikey iron law podcast sponsored by the
UFC and Morgan everybody team what do
you I know this Mike definitely is a
very passionate guy I would already
assume what happened between you two and
I know Mike he's actually a big-time
Seattle Seahawks fan so during my nine
is Aaron we would kind of go at he's
like stuff I understand he may push the
button we know you two boxes go here
we're giving you that gaming realness
unfortunately our Lord addict might not
be available today he's having some
issues even going to remove and all
again we apologize everyone first time
off we've had a lot of things going on
actually I was away Lord King had a
glorious birthday he had celebrate you
know also we have gone sovereign
he's been extra busy and stuff like that
so you know we get into it we got a lot
to do
you know if I hadn't jumped in you can
freed it just jump right on in if he
wants to right into it and I've been
going on so I want to set this thing off
actually I'll set it off with um
obviously I was away for Guardian con
big destiny fan as the Lord's know and I
just wanted to talk about that briefly a
really experienced in how just to see a
gaming community come together and
donate to charity you know they raised
over a million again you know for st.
Jude's and the kids and just seeing a
lot of content providers and streamers
and things that nature was always good
to see so it's good to link up with my
fellow Guardians my brethren is coming
together meeting at the Tampa
Fairgrounds really cool experience if
you guys get a chance to check it out
and I'm also on the tip of that was a
destiny to beta was announced so I
wanted to bring this to the Lord so
obviously there's a couple of things
that we're gonna expect we're gonna have
a homecoming opening mission and
cinematics from the dumpling campaign
we're gonna have a countdown crucible
mode which I got a chance to play at e3
which is kind of like a 44
I believe control inverted spire strike
some subclasses and new social space
called the farm so little British to the
roundtable if anybody got a chance to
check out any of this news or what do
they think about it let's start off with
Lord dizzy because I've been curious to
see you know what's your feedback on
this destiny to information you know I
I'm probably the worst person to even
start off with this just because not for
the reasons you think they did it okay
okay
I know that I've stated this before I've
said it on Twitter I'm pretty sure I
talked to a few of you about it it's not
about the exclusiveness it's not about
disliking destiny because you know we
know how I felt about vanilla destiny
you know I never try to hide that you
know they did make a rebound with um I
felt like the taken king was amazing I
really wish that they could have
duplicated that with the rise of iron
or whatever it's called oh yeah and I
was actually looking forward to destiny
to a little bit you know I was like I'll
get back into it
mm-hmm here was my problem I feel that
the developer is lazy and the reason why
I say this is it goes back to the whole
you know I know
Xbox 1x you know fanatics are gonna say
you know for you know 60 frames per
second 4k I'm not looking for 4k okay
but there's no way that you cannot tell
me that even the ps4 Pro cannot run
destiny - at 60 frames per second if the
PC is running at an unlocked there is no
way that even the ps4 Pro can't run this
game we're not looking for parity
between the the regular ps4 and the ps4
Pro or the Xbox one and the 1x don't
talk about parity because the PC is
running at an unlocked framerate mm-hmm
so to me that's ridiculous and that's
actually why I wrote destiny 2 up just
because the frame per second okay and
they wanted a they wanted to use other
excuses for it you know and I know that
a lot of Xbox you know gamers for
destiny
you know like been added about it
because you know the 1x is supposed to
be pretty powerful you know that's what
they say on the streets so I looked at
this game in even with the ps4 Pro you
know stuff you can't tell me that even
the ps4 Pro can't run it at 60 frames
per second it should have been in stone
at that near lock 60 frames per second
God so as a result of of that news
coming out your whole feeling towards
destiny changed because you feel as a
standard like it should it be
automatically hitting at 60 and as a
result now that's turned you off from
even thinking about considering the beta
or purchasing oh it has it has I'll
probably try the bait out just you know
just to try it out you know say that
well I tried it out but it should have
been at the
60 frames per second I like what they're
doing with the game like they did
exactly what I wanted I wanted I wanted
the Cabal you know and it looks like
that the story looks like it will be
pretty good the the villain he looks
like he might be one of the best
villains in Colma Carl a villain that's
coming out here like oh I'm gonna kill
and Massacre everybody this is this is
something a little bit deeper mm-hmm so
the game looks like that it could be
good I'm just I'm boycotting it because
I feel that the developers late you know
by you playing the debate is you already
pre-ordered the game because you're not
playing the baby they're not saying hey
dizzy check this out the baby's out
either you preorder get out of later
actually I just as prior to the podcast
asked Laura kognito if it's gonna be an
open beta because if it's an open beta
yes I will try it out because I do want
to see the other things that they made
little you know changes to maybe down
the line whenever they they put it on a
major sellout consider picking it up but
I am definitely not gonna be there day
one I don't support that because again I
filled the pre-order initial first but
they do plan on making it open
eventually to the public I forget the
dates now excuse me I leave late the one
I'm gonna say the 19th but dokoni
21st to the 23rd is the console right
okay so um I mean my question to this is
basic I don't know if you got a chance
or duty to hear from Luke Smith and Mark
Noseworthy when they were talking about
why they felt they could not hit it or
console and from way it was explained
was that they're saying it's CPU bound
and that there's no way possible that
these current systems based on a CPU
stand quite not a GPU standpoint can hit
it so that being that infant being when
you got that information you still don't
buy that you still feel that this is
still don't buy just lazy crap games out
there there's plenty of games out there
they're running high
res and they can lock the 60
frames-per-second there's not enough
going on on the screen even in destiny
to say they even the the computation
power is not there to run at 60 frames
per second there are a lot of
platformers they have a lot going on the
screen and are still locked at 60 frames
per second okay so these are these games
open-world games and are these games
consist of fire teams and other things
going on I just want something that I'm
not I'm not trying to hate I'm just
trying to comparable destinies doing
that's all that's also gonna have to be
reliant on if this is a pure server
bound game but from my understanding
weren't they moving to a different kind
of server support which would also kind
of free up a lot of that computation
because the server's not gonna have to
compute it all because para is gonna be
done through the console so again
they're full of [ __ ] to me they're
trying to use something as a a parity
clause because we don't want to give an
advantage and you know using that CPU
excuse no I don't buy it I'd know and
they know this is not by oh that they
can do it I'm not I just don't I don't
when you when you have this type of like
living game and you're trying to make it
function across generations across with
Xbox we're talking about not like a base
Xbox one Xbox 1s Xbox one X and then ps4
ps4 Pro you that's the that's when you
really have to program to the least
common denominator because you're gonna
want to like people to play together
so yeah it's CP it's bound to the CPU
and it's bound to the lowest functioning
CPU it's the only way it's gonna work
across all of these consoles otherwise
the whole concept of mid console reflets
mid console cycle refreshes not gonna
work it's not gonna work I mean yeah I
love it if they can give me a mode on
the Xbox one X that allows me to play it
at 60 I that would be
they're not gonna do that they're just
not gonna do it on PCs always could have
been the Wild West it's you know they
it's understood you're gonna get those
options on PC but unfortunately it's
just what it is on console if there's
one thing that that kind of holds you
know I've always argued that that these
these console refreshes aren't holding
back older games but that really doesn't
apply to these living world games
because again if you want all these
people to play together it's just gonna
be concessions that you can have to make
so let me let me jump in in defense of
Disney which I'm gonna surprise my fan
base now I will say this there is some
things that he is say is truth in
reference to the whole you know a lot of
destiny calculations are done by this
kind of hybrid server bound slash you
know I mean like um
dedicated said well we know there's no
full dedicated service but the way they
do their instance matchmaking and stuff
like that on the PvE standpoint they use
a lot of network resources so do you
think solve let maybe because if they
went a full because the biggest Omni
I'll be honest with you like my biggest
argument with them right now is that to
me the honest and everybody's all upper
or 60 frames to me the biggest egregious
thing is that is where our side which
are Kelowna communities lit right now
that's what I saw what an anchorman
that's why I saw it dizzy because that's
inexcusable you have franchises like
Call of Duty right you have these huge
money getters right you know your
community that is the top thing on the
list for you and I mean wanting as far
as community wants right right in every
year how many iterations are Call of
Duty always right like there's no
dedicated servers you find out it's this
hybrid garbage or what have you so it's
just like it's one of those things in my
opinion when you're making hand over
fist there's no reason why you can't
have dedication and this is this this
goes back to that this is the action
Activision conundrum
this is this day they're in control of
it and Call of Duty then control the
destiny battlenet is their thing
this is they're gonna they gonna put
money into that and that's what they
cookie you so this M me and again it
sucks it's such but they're just again
they want to continue making money hand
over fist so they know it honors that's
theirs and know whichever way it
functions is the way that it functions
and again when it comes to the point
where so egregious that people are not
able to play the game as intended or
properly then maybe maybe they would
address that but be surprised where I
take my stance because I'm gonna go do a
boardroom and I'm gonna go with Bungie
on this right now honey Bungie is going
to like like sovereigns Lord Salman said
they're going to cater to the least
common denominator because they don't
need to exclude anyone now should they
have a 1 player mode that's 4k 60 frames
per second for the console that can do
it yeah yeah it should be but then then
look and dizzy is right Lord disease
right on this desk comes into laziness
because that's another set of
programming so they're like what hell we
should we do it is so but that goes back
to the resources again at Activision and
the resources again at bungee and and
they saying that you know financially it
makes no sense because if we just put it
for 30 frames per second like we write
one code and that's it I get that part
right there I know they wanted to get
the return back off for this because it
was a heavy investment in these Bungie
dudes and I'm know that they're
notoriously difficult alright they're
notoriously difficult they're like these
whiny little spoiled brats season title
children that you know we came over with
this IP and this IP is gonna do good
because we know what's best and the
develop are the the company Activision
is same
yeah but you know the the people in the
streets is talking and they don't really
like dis from you what we built our
story up alright so the main talking
points was their story was sucking
alright story looks very good from
outside story looks fantastic it looks
like it's getting me back in it looks
like he's getting dizzy is curious about
it so they worked on that aspect the
service what not broke listen I
understand but what's what what what
isn't broke they don't want to go and
say okay we're gonna put dedicated
service we're gonna invest all this
money into dedicated service and just
like Lord sovereign said net this is not
built off for that so what you're
telling you the company is a change your
philosophy we invested in with this
thing and this is what makes money
across the boards for us weird we're not
gonna switch it up midstream just for
this one game this one got you title now
my question it's gonna question to you
in red first today is but like tilled or
Dizzy's point you is that acceptable
like is it acceptable if you build your
company around this model and for you to
switch it up okay what what happens when
the whole destiny dies out right
alright and they have these servers okay
so the next game is gonna go on this and
they got a bet that the next game is
gonna make money no that's that's not
how it works
so pretty much you're saying from a
corporate standpoint they're just gonna
stick with the philosophy that they can
Delanie they're not gonna change no not
now now to Dizzy's point you know do we
as the consumer take a stand do ya know
by okay we play games for a reason see
we remember when it wasn't any service
yeah I just want to jump in on it I mean
the whole thing as far as the you know
the whole lazy developer
I'm gonna disagree with autism that
obviously but you know my thing is this
I think as gamers sometimes we have to
be leery of what I consider like
armchair developer and I'm not trying to
say that that there's no way that this
thing can't be done I'm not in any way
trying to discredit this and say like it
is not possible it's very well made
possible and shout out to a stooge in a
chat you know a lot of this also I want
to bring it to the attention is that I
with for cake being such a focus there
should also be options like if we're
going mid console generation refresh
right for 1080 60 option right like my
if 4k is is is gonna push things to that
level it not everyone has a 4k TV we
should have some things that are
comfortable that's the first one the
second point is like okay I don't want
to disrespect a dev and say when they
tell me the reason why they can't do
something is because it's CPU mount for
me to just go to them and say nah you
full I'm a techie and again I'm not
trying to say that it's impossible it
may very well be you know for me I'm
just I tend to concede in that respect
you know so that's just where my
position on it I know a lot of people do
agree well or decision I think a man and
Chad gone crazy I know where he's at as
far as first-person shooters are
concerned I know he thinks that destiny
is not traditional open-world game but
it's also not a standard FPS in a
traditional sense either I mean no other
games that you know do the fireteam
thing that people come into your
instance and stuff like that but um you
know like I said we'll see what's up
you know as far as position I want to
kind of get back into the actual beta
stuff we're gonna talk right a lot of
people like shout out to my boy or Lord
doc cupcaking these guys these people
like you who like I'm taking a stance
I'm not buying this you know if people
say hey I'm not a Bonnie I'm not going
for this exclusive crap anymore you know
I mean like why am i paying as Xbox guys
obviously you know why are we paying for
Less content so I get all the arguments
and I respect it fireplace there's
two points that I actually thought that
were pretty cool about this just need to
and some of the stuff that we kind of
like briefly mentioned it the whole kick
ball into a net got soccer and then
Brenda chicken which clearly they're
they're trying to bite off you know
Zelda and older scrolls with this should
be adding a lot more things like that
absolutely absolutely no uh lower King
what about you have you already any
information about the beta what's going
to be included anything except from it
that I've heard about anything that I
can get on destiny to excites me like I
heard a little bit about the farm well
you know how I go when it when it's that
stuff reading that stuff and I want the
excitement I have to break that cycle
because of the podcast so I'm forced to
listen look taking this information that
will otherwise spoil my destroy my
wonder why there's no more wunderbar so
I'm gonna become one of these jaded
shout out to anchorman oh one of these
jaded
podcasters and I understand because we
are forced to taking this information
and report back to the guys that are
dead aren't and in or or is too busy and
they they tune into the podcast to get
the latest or whatever's was going on so
I got I'm forced to taking this
information look at it and I can't shut
it off what's just what's seen once is
you can't unsee it
so yeah I had to look at the farm yeah I
was I was this I was happy but
disappointed in fact that I just blew my
own self up watching this stuff because
you definitely like me me you and loss
all we come from that ilk that we as
gamers like to be surprised we don't
want to water much cuz you like you want
that newness feeling right
coming from the loss of the non destiny
player you were in vanilla field about
these updates did you catch anything you
catch any information yeah I think and
for me what excites me the most about it
is the fact that they're you know
they're fixing know that story stuff the
story elements is the stuff that I
gravitate more to so the fact that you
know that initial story mission that we
saw when it was first revealed it's
gonna actually be playable and we
actually you know feel and touch that
and kind of see how they've incorporated
all that new stuff into the actual
gameplay because for me I always wanted
I always wanna give to show me their
story like to show him integrate me in
the story whether it be like with
interesting characters and stuff like
that the grimoire cards stuff and the
first one was cool but it's all stuff
that should have been in the game proper
not having some line looking for this
extra lore so I want to be in get I want
to be brought into the Destiny world by
the game itself the game plane the
situations and scenarios they put me in
so that's what I'm most interested to to
contemplate the crucible stuff I fell
off of that early on it and destiny one
so I definitely like to see that the all
the cool stuff they can add to the
social space again that's another thing
that kind of engages you more in that
world a little fun stuff that you could
do in the social space it makes the
world feel more alive and I think that's
for me that was the biggest negative for
destiny one that didn't feel like it was
a real inhabited world like you just get
together with your friends you'd go on a
mission and then you get to loot and
then you go back and do the same thing
and you just you know rinse and repeat
but it doesn't feel like a living world
so I'm hoping that that's what they do
initially that's not a cheap shot the
aggravators say if he's not falling for
the trailers like it's vertical
standpoint of a true open world
single-player experience and that's his
ilk so really kind of stimuli
we'll have any of you pre-ordered I'm
assuming you have not really correct I'm
gonna pre-order like two days before the
beta comes out I'm giving my money um I
remember I wasn't gonna pre-order I
wasn't gonna play the beta I wasn't
gonna do that stuff because I wanted to
be excited for the game but um again
I'm forced to spend my money for you
guys and a report back for you guys so
y'all can hear me rant about how I
didn't like this so I don't like that
now I did get a chance to play the PC
version and I'm going to tell you I am
buying the PC version I'm going to let
you know that right off the bat my PC I
have dual 1080s
running ready to play in 4k 60 frames
per second well actually it'd be like
200 frames per second but I can only see
60 like 27 um but I'm going to be
playing it now what I'd be playing on my
xbox one it yes of course all my friends
got a PC playing on a PC I'm going to
meet new people in the PC world I'm
gonna be in that space so usually are
you gonna concurrently run balls I have
no choice this is the game that I'm
gonna be dual dual welding so much
appeasing I can't stress this enough to
anybody that's listening I played it in
4k 60 frames per second in a private
setting I had a chance to sit with a
developer sitting with me going over it
shoutout to our Lord ant the ruler he
was there as my photographer he caught
all the footage that footage will be
shown once I put the podcast up they
gave us a flash drive to walk away with
with our gameplay that was captured in
4k I can't stress it enough by telling
you
Lord zero T V zero I can't stress it
enough by telling you how impressed I
was visually and control wise is a big
difference control Y from 60 frames per
second and 30 frames per second and in
the first-person shooter is essential to
have that twitch gameplay going
when I hit trust me when I tell you this
the PC version and I know the master
race is out this say yes King the point
where y'all actually all on the top okay
so it was playing in the i7 alright so
you already know if it's CPU bound that
i7 was tearing apart
alright GPU wise there was a 4k 60
frames per second it looked glorious
right it looked like this is what my
money is for so I don't care if I'm
spending that extra money here my
purchase is gonna probably top out at
$200 combined in both systems I don't
give a damn
okay I mean it's a valid point because I
mean I mean a Cardian con I got a chance
shut out 250 Tefft and fall out plays
all the guys in community because I had
the heart-to-heart with him I'm like you
guys the streamers and I'm seeing you
guys at the PC gaming show obviously you
guys big how-to video on how to make a
gaming rig and I'm like what's going on
oh yeah Jeff is [ __ ] but I do it and I
was straight up let me anyway like look
man arm you know from a visual
standpoint I think I'm gonna start an
additional community on PC you know as
far when destiny 2 comes out so it is
luring people to what Lord Kings point
is before we get into that we've got
Lord 0 d OG in that law when you posted
that I would ever time to chat I
now wait for it to get in the podcast Oh
give her brother drop out a little extra
for how well it out our boy shot boil or
drop out designs check him out he's
doing this thing I hit for IOP
definitely so I know you jumped in the
tail in this conversation I want it
cause it's just caught up Lord dizzy out
here be creating all type of controversy
in these streets he's not about that
life
you know he's not about that thirty
frames per second life so I want to get
your comment on that and then also just
with the information that's been
released by a bungee so far with the
destiny to beta so good lord zero the
floor is yours as far as the console pc
thing goes I could get where people
would want to go to the PC that's fine
for people who have something capable
Kourtney personally I've always been a
console gamer first and foremost so I'm
just gonna stay to Xbox I understand the
benefits easy but I just PC gaming just
isn't my kind of thing keyboard and
mouse cat again the CPU and upgrade in
the GPU and that stuff like that i watch
the farm and i think the coolest thing
about the farm that they mentioned I
don't know if y'all caught it or if you
mentioned it yet is it starts out pretty
barren and will found a whole lot of
stuff in it but as a story progresses it
actually grows kind of like the actual
community which I thought it's dream
cooled because the tower just say snag
this the whole time it was just they
wanted to detail a little bit and they
said the longer you go on more buildings
are gonna show what there's gonna be
more stores stalls I'm gonna show up in
pcs coming into so thank you to be
honest with you I thought that was a
bunch of the smoking me
because they the same thing with the
tower and our whole back area and it
would open it up for high-end banner or
they below p'n it up for little things
and it will go and come at a pay you
know but I can fall because if you
started in it and remember this this
destiny to is gonna be a vanilla version
as well so when you do DLC they're not
straying from this formula you're not
fooling anybody when you're saying that
oh yeah with it's available for
everybody this is the same lie they told
y'all the first time don't fall for it
comes out and Joey didn't buy the DLC
they still want Joey to play so destiny
2 is vanilla they're not saying that but
it is vanilla destiny 2 and then when
they're the DLCs come out they're gonna
start separating it to her you know from
possible from the haves and have no is
it true because they're not giving you
the DLC for free so you're purchasing
the DLC and that's gonna separate the
heard again because a lot of times we
went inside the rooms and we like I
let's start up this mission how come
it's not starting
Joey did down I'm downloading it now so
that's gonna happen and it's gonna
happen again and it's saying is this
back to the same thing instead of it I
know Lord sovereign has this topic a
little bit later so I'm not gonna delve
too much into it
but instead of putting this DLC as pay
for sell the whole game complete so that
is no longer vanilla this and the third
it's one whole game when you first
purchase the game all the DLC and
everything is included so nobody's
excluded and we're asking just from
Activision who won't come is dedicated
servers is not too hard to say alright
dudes is 7995 get out on a lay down and
it's not and then when you say well why
is this 79 because everything is
included because we don't want to
exclude anyone it keeps everything all
intact sort of that one dude that
purchased at one time
he's down with you let's say he starts
playing afraid there's a separate crime
I understand from that I just want to
get lower we kind of stepped over did
not learn any lessons and it what you're
saying about the social space though and
how that could be a lie I would be right
there with you honestly
but the only thing that's making me feel
like they're actually gonna do it is
this time around and the beta um for the
beta for destiny one they said hey do
this mission run around the entire tower
the whole time we're not gonna hire take
from me right this time they're only on
one day they're gonna give you one hour
to explore it that's it you don't get to
run around and on this beta I don't
think they would do that unless you know
they didn't want you to see things or
you know see changes going on so I mean
I feel like they they might maybe they
over exaggerated a little bit you
drinking the kool-aid this is what
you're telling me you got a big bowl of
porridge we got one day to get busy yeah
okay when you coming from just from the
standpoint of okay
I hate when games come out and like for
example like I love what let's just use
the opposite
I love with Halo 5 which it's like boom
all the DLC everyone's getting it
because it does suck when you know
because you had a guy like anything man
yeah guys I remember that had vanilla
was excited for taking King and all that
stuff
I'll rock your world I mean the house of
wolves comes out the way Activision a
strong on that situation like they'll
lock out content no you can't do the
daily stuff like that so I get it but in
the other stamp when I do see like the
world of war I mean it's the Waterworld
craft model which is pretty much with
the American game was that can continue
myself I was going on the DLC thing now
I think the DLC should be free I'm you
know we are we excited the question is
can we convince Lord dizzy to come to
the dark side put away his his 30 frames
per song differences now if you play a
week of art with him he will give you a
week of this playing that dag on art
they blamed what's going on with Xbox
one X so we go move on no I can't be in
here without speaking about you know
Lord Lord is let's let's talk some walks
it sits on a really stung just before
mat tell us what's going on in these arc
streets now school me what's going on we
need to know okay okay I don't know if
anybody else has been seeing a couple of
these tweets being or not
not even just tweets a couple articles
talking about the dayz devs talking
about Ark survival evolved and
moving to what was supposed to be their
their release launch pricing which is a
$60 title okay and for probably about
the last two years it's been running at
an average of a thirty dollar game in a
preview state in a in a gaming preview
in a in a state where they're gonna
continuously fix things and continuously
break things so that they can try to fix
things
so that when it releases is not as buggy
is the people who have been playing for
two years you know that's kind of the
incentive that you have whenever you
play like a game that's in a game
preview state is it's gonna be at a
lower price because they want you you're
pretty much mean you're paying to play
the beta but you're also paying at a
discounted rate that you get to keep the
game once the game releases correct
right so which is the whole purpose of
every preview right yes and August on
August 8th despite a lot of people
saying and here's my son coming over
here trying to talk to the mic with you
guys he actually watches me play the
game I digress despite a lot of people
saying oh Ark is never gonna release Ark
has a release date of August 8th ok so
that was my major beef thank God thank
ya so so recently they decided okay
we're just gonna move the pricing on
both on Steam and Xbox and the
PlayStation 4 it moved to the $60 price
point and here comes Dean Hall I don't
know if anybody knows ease always you
know the good old creator of dayz the
game that has been in preview for about
what four or five years as personally so
I had his second game canceled and has a
really atrocious looking third game
creating the the studio wild card for
moving this to the $60 price point
calling them greedy the game is not
worth $60 now there Dale Earl
lorda zero you play the game just on
single-player you don't even play on an
official Arc server where you know many
people play in your perspective if that
makes T dollars for the for what they're
selling you well as is the Lord snow I
determined help what a game is worst why
how long I play the game right everybody
knows us I have put thousands of hours
in destiny was $30 to me even in DLC i
paid including a scorched-earth 55
roughly for art and i have I think three
or four thousand hours into it so and
that's just yeah I was just pointing out
that's retention right so go ahead right
yeah and like like you said that's
mostly coming from a guy who does 99% of
single-player my very very very rarely
do PvP or official service at all and as
a whole nother that's a whole other pond
kettle right there are people who hop on
every day play for hours on end to get
their base ready to raids tamed I know
it was all this other kind of stuff and
you know that's the kind of experience
that is you could speak up speak on more
fluently because he plays that but to me
personally hell yeah the game is worth
six dollars for a single player if
they're into that survival dinosaur
aspect it's kind of like minecraft
minecraft' we're not talking about a
game like that had like Sean Murray who
says all these small animals beautiful
things appeared almost is correct I
would care to I would care to say at
least 98 percent of what the developers
at Studio wildcard said that they were
going to do with art have appeared in
the game in some form or a matter and if
they couldn't make it happen they let
you know
we weren't out in the cold and and PC
gamers love their mods they have to be a
from Bethesda they have to be one of the
most mods supporting developers I've
ever seen in gaming young this this game
isn't worth $60 according to the Daisy
dev who has yet to release a single jump
in the as y'all as the Lords know I am
extremely arc no art expert I watched
you guys I listened to you guys things
and I see the passion you know you guys
have for this game shoutout the Lord
Carol I see you even indoctrinated my
boy care I noticed whenever you guys get
into that it's it's just it's like a
coke
it's going down and and I respect it so
I see the power he's getting right so
let's start for them get it my question
to you guys these when the game first
came out in preview was it like I'm not
a thirty final preview what was the
previous at starting 60 30 bucks price
to thirty five thirty pounds now this is
what I remember I remember during the
course of the game that they announced
dlc and shouting get into that you know
I did feel away about that because my
feeling was a game at that point was not
released that was my issue at first with
them like you know my thing to me the
most positive news that I heard was when
you guys say release date cuz I'll be
honest I was it confident it was gonna
happen I was very nervous like improve
your Lord I know the update
I see the updates I go to play bar
gaming I checked what you guys are doing
is if I do see the things that happened
they very receptive to the always
engaging you guys which I like
feel like a hustle I'm saying in that
standpoint but I was too certain that it
was early state was coming up now we
have a release date
oh I'm saying so now you're telling me
that okay again clarify because I'm are
ignorant what's the price of the PC
steam stuff or how much how much is that
what was it prior thirty-five across the
board this same model and were they the
same boat like the council where they
also like in a preview state and you get
steamed had an advantage of you know not
to cut the only thing that the or PC
gamers had an advantage of was that the
modders were able to get in there and
put mods up a lot quicker and they could
do it there's a lot more going on for
the PC and everything and that respected
now okay what they've been doing is arc
is very receptive of what's going on on
PC and what the gamers on the PC like
and if it looks like it's something that
is a big hit the cool thing that the
developers have been doing is bringing
those mod developers on to bring that to
the console versions of the game pretty
much for the PC guys was similar to
console guys lookyou early committed for
the 35 and now basically what's
happening is oK we've announced our
launch date and now it's like $60 now
for these guys right that's what they
said is that is that I'm just yeah yeah
yeah I mean I get it no person great and
swear to God know your mother going but
I'm glad his release can go and already
know you want to go so I'm just gonna
give it to you right this
I'm gonna start off with the fact that
I'm diametrically opposed to the preview
program all right so I think that's a
lot of failure and I think they should
shut it down and I think they should
shut it down just because he yeah game
all right because your game actually say
yo check this out $35 bring it in and I
thought it was supposed to be $35 and
when the game come out I got it
he's our brother it's that's not how
it's gonna go it's $35 ingenuous ed yo
for me to play your game all these hours
here's 4,000 hours of my time and
feedback and giving y'all all this this
data's gold brothers you don't
understand they pay people for this this
is actually whole companies is made up
of this and you guys are doing it
basically for free you paid to do this
you pay to get in the club and spin your
own records this is what you did and
then they say you know what hey listen
you wanna play additional records
that'll be another $5 they charging you
oh boy
deal see for a game that's not complete
we'll give you a call with three wheels
we gonna let you buy another go we'll
see ya this is the most craziest thing I
and if you thought it couldn't get any
crazier they say yo y'all want the date
right the date is coming to fall game
it's coming out that you've been playing
anyway the full game is coming out in
August 8th $65 brother I think this is a
bait and switch fellas um because I did
say that
it was 35 and they said no no you're
going to pay for the full game on this
date this date is the date as the money
comes into the bank so there it was
bought it has
full game for 35 bucks you didn't have
to write now did you buy it that's right
they knew they had you wanna think of
people didn't pick it up because I
remember it was roasted for that [ __ ]
they know that price you know what to do
right you know it's the best part about
that a lot of people they pick it up at
all
and they want a fall game when it come
out right my thing is if you want people
to beta test your stuff give it to him
for free if you want people to to test
your DLC give it to him for free cuz
there's a test stop charging people so
the same hair your play Ark for free
until release comes up comes out and if
you want to continue to play the game
pay six dollars right here I'm buying
the game sixty frames per second on a 4k
television because they said something
that appealed to me they said they were
the only games doing the full case 60 so
what are they actually doing it then you
can enjoy that and you're welcome
because we did this help the game gets
that way appreciate your hard work and
they give you all a sticker
gave you nothing they gave me game
everybody try to fix it around I
understand exactly what your point is in
everything and I get it quite a bit okay
but it is it is of the it's just the
formula the way the game preview now
granted Ark isn't the first one that
sold into the preview program and to
getting people to do this and let me
tell you I like I I don't think that the
preview program should operate on that
free model okay a lot of these
developers that do the free model or not
the free model the the game preview are
not your Activision's they're not the
EAS they're not the rockstars they're
not the Bethesda's they don't have the
resources that these companies have that
they could open up a a completely free
free-to-play where you go in there and
you try it out before they sell it out
okay so these are these are independent
independent developers that they don't
have those resources so that's why they
they make you pay into it you know with
the the preview program so that they can
pay their developers to continue to try
to work on this because you don't want
your developers to go hungry how else
are they going to be able to afford to
pay these people to make this game right
otherwise these games will never release
this is your unfortunately this is your
players this is your this is your this
is your right when it comes when it
comes Xbox it will come to Xbox as a
what a complete game reckoning it ain't
going any it's not coming as is a
complete game they're not done with the
game that's the thing it's gonna come in
the preview program watch so you
you will in the game is your willingness
for you these preview programs are going
and everything and I am hundred percent
I can under 100% understand the whole
DLC dang hey while you're within the the
preview and everything I get that
hundred percent I can't defend it we
don't give a [ __ ] about that we're gonna
pay for it anyways okay that's that's
you know just though that the nature of
a lot of the people who play Ark and
everything I'm not saying it was a bad
game I actually I actually love the
concept behind the game once shout-out
to Lord fat boy
he told me that he got kidnapped by some
dudes amazing I never forget dizzy
breaking down I mean what happened what
I need that some type of was the end of
a dissolving of a clan and and the
nastiness that it involved in
Tom Iovino turn your best friends
against each other yes serious in nature
like I'll lose watch they run away from
it cuz I see it's like it's like a drug
it's like I already have you know we go
Gump in our bed - is there obviously we
had the Marvel thing going on and I made
some comments you know a couple of week
weeks back and reference to what's going
on with the characters and Lord dizzy
he's a firm believer that the Fantastic
Four and Silver Surfer was my favorite
is copping to the MCU he is convinced so
we have going on you know it does happen
I have to get almost off real quick
because we got I got to get him in on
this also I didn't get his feedback at
all
as far as they just announced they just
announced that they're pushing back the
final release of the game don't think I
don't think though Spencer is gonna be
like you know what now we're gonna hold
off and it's not gonna launch with the X
1 X 1 X I think they're gonna put it in
preview and I think they gonna let us
preview like I said I stand behind my
word there's no problem you shoot me
that email and you get that digital call
and it'll be poppin for you I don't
believe Phil is gonna make that much of
a blunder so just yeah I'll shoot you my
email
full game it'll be playing this is the
thing though the heating begin the game
runs is so well now like it's only it's
only like optimizations and adding more
stuff like it's not like a free preview
copy of what I would take from you I
don't know what game would be out by
then Seekers dizzy or Lord zero we
purchase in this game from we will find
out exactly who's purchase in this game
will be purchased for me there so you
can't buy double buy me a game so what I
don't know what game will be coming out
at that time but it will be a game of my
choosing and we will announce it on here
get lost I'll just real quick with the
whole that like what's the timeframe
what the timeframe is that we're getting
we're getting arc on Xbox one x or xbox
one this year whatever
no no whatever way is released it has to
be released either as a full release or
preview if it goes into the preview
program then they win if okay doesn't
touch the preview program and it comes
out after release haha the king wins
I've never seen a game lost on the
screen and they said this game was
coming out
[Music]
he's talking about when they said we got
a preview
Oh what is it that one twenty dollar
game that wasn't previewed that died
immediately we happy few they didn't say
it was a launch right but it was it was
on but they said that this game is a
game all right quickly yeah you know to
me I think the whole change in price
again is bad optics and the fact that
they when you're trying to when you when
you go to final release and then you're
trying to release physical copies at the
same time that messes up everything
because now you have to you have to
adhere to what the MSRP is in store and
then when you're trying to sell like you
know limited editions like statues and
stuff like that it messes up the entire
pricing model so to me it's just one of
those things where it's like you're
trying to get the new person in by
purchasing this this physical copy of
the game and adding all these extras
it's the
balance as soon as they find out that
there's a cheaper version somewhere and
they're not that person who really wants
all that physical stuff yeah
the difference the difference isn't
gonna be it's not gonna be fair to them
so to remedy the optics they have to
bring the price up it sucks it
absolutely sucks it looks horrible but
in the long term if you want to sell
this game long term and you want to
continue to sell the physical copies of
it you got to do it so it is ugly it's
very ugly with it now with my loss I've
had a question for you with the
announced that an Xbox one X you know
enhancement to UM Ark I know for me
personally that kind of exciting because
that was really my only do for the game
y'all dizzy how many visions they were
like that was out just I've known a
games deep here's here's the crazy part
and here's what's actually this is the
reason why you have the game preview and
everything and for people to you know be
in this kind of optimization they did
from from the initial release of art to
the standpoint that they're at right now
is night and day the game looks so much
better and runs so much smoother than
what it did but on occasion they do make
it a lot of blunders I'm not gonna even
pretend that they're you know they're
perfect but every time they fix
something they break about two more
things which you know is life of a
develop yes recently they had a patch
that went out that actually really
[ __ ] up the reload times of actually
the rendering distance and what they
ended up having to do is they actually
had to downscale some of the Dinos and
their resolutions in order to try to fix
what was going on so for about a week we
were running around with some dinos it
look like that they were being ran on
the ps2 and it's it's so crazy to see
something like everything else is get it
like in people don't realize this but
the game is actually running above 900 P
and for a game with this much processing
that it requires and as expansive and
open world of this
it's pretty amazing there on a console
that they're running it said above 900
feet I digress
but it's funny seeing something that is
you know at that at that resolution next
is something that looks like it should
be on ps2 it almost looks like somebody
like you know hacked something and threw
it in there and it's just crazy but you
know they have a very long way I really
cannot wait
it's happy to play xbox Xbox glad I
think they're my overall question
because we went completely in on our
park itself does the dayz developer have
a write the dayz develop this man has a
game where you pay a price right to get
an airdrop that another player can
[ __ ] steal from you real nice quinoa
and
in the middle of the sky somewhere over
the map we'll just drop it will slowly
fall for everybody to see everyone's
lining their bets up right now it's like
Bette Lloyd let's move when he knows
that he is toast
well he really do is get his gaming up
how much time I put in playing it alive
zero I'm gonna come fresh face you face
you I'm a freestyle all over you and
that's this part of the Lord I'm not
gonna pick it up mother look at Alan
with the buds off I'm gonna freestyle
all over you beat you and you won't buy
me a game that I'm gonna be personal
yeah I think this comment about anything
like that you don't say so you know he
really needs to fall back you know yeah
how long did they take to come out and
here's the thing though if he had
commented on the aforementioned DLC that
came out scorched earth I could kind of
understand that right the kids as much
as I'll defend it because well I love
the game the DLC is worth it to me I get
why people complain about it I always
have so I would understand why he would
make a comment on that but jacking up
the game I mean it it's gonna be an
official full game it would only makes
sense to charge their price right
absolutely I mean it just again I mean I
think the logit agree with dislike that
to me unless someone tells me
differently why is it dev would you even
comment on another dev though I guess
that's why you in your feelings
game twice as big as yours get
successful twice a time
it sounds like professional jealousy I
mean it just sounds like it you know as
much as anybody can say with anyone
about Ark and I've even had my hating
moments on it once you guys said release
date is I can say it's over or burying a
hatchet they came due date delivered on
their promise they gave what the
community wanted isn't it well you can
say so do need to do is like ya know but
everyone's doubt I was gonna move on to
the next topic does you good yeah so got
lots of up and you want to talk about
cop I got really excited to talk about
this is kind of the possible death of
single player DLC or somebody what do
you got for us
yes so a little over a week ago um
basically there was a Facebook post from
this company called Sinclair networks
indicating that they have been working
on single player DLC for Mass Effect
Andromeda and that Bioware jumped in and
cancelled it hi Bioware came out and
said we don't know who the hell these
people are the hoax but what if forced
them to do though the funny thing is
that it forced them to address the issue
of not talking about any sort of DLC for
Mass Effect Andromeda if you know common
sense we might tell you late they're
probably not gonna do any single player
DLC for this game anyway
it had middling reviews for us and the
fact that they broke up the team
afterwards to serve as support for other
games like Battlefront to like like
anthem like no need for speed there's
they probably don't have the manpower
together to actually put together a team
to make single player DLC for um for
Mass Effect Andromeda so what that got
me thinking was like in general this
type of DLC over the past I would say to
three years has kind of seen a decline
and and and especially when you're
talking about coming back to these big
these big single-player games and
creating more DLC for it it just seems
like people play the game initially and
they move on and especially in this day
and age you're seeing a lot of games
that are getting this DLC be more of the
living game something like a destiny or
something like the division or the mmo's
people are talking a lot about Final
Fantasy 14 again in a storm blood and
things like that so again the
distinctive points to those type of
games are a gameplay gameplay to keep
people coming back and the loot loot is
the thing that keeps people coming back
and engaged when you know that you can
play the same mission over and over
again but you'll get better and better
gear this is what brings people back to
these games and obviously these
single-player games don't have that so
so my questions the Lords is you know
what do these single-player games
have they been doing what do they need
to do to keep people engaged and coming
back to their those worlds now this is a
leave negating but those worlds and
another thing that I notice is rampant
in Tendo always late to the game but it
seems to be working for them
Nintendo now has for the first time ever
especially with Zelda are incorporating
paid DLC into their games and do we
think especially with it with the recent
drop for the first part of that DLC for
our a little while do we think it's
working for them and if it is working
for them why is it working for them what
makes their their DLC different no
single player games juicy anybody wants
to jump in I got a lot to say but I want
anybody go for it I think it's kind of
stupid to have DLC for single-player
games I really don't see the relevance
in it um the fact that Nintendo is doing
it our brother the wireless candidate
for Game of the Year so you had a rabid
fan base that is behind the game that
can't get so much from playing miniscule
parts of the game to add anything extra
to it to the experience that will
purchase it I myself didn't see the
value in that DLC so I didn't purchase
it
I won't purchase it until actually they
open up other parts of the map or
something of that nature I don't care
for doing trials or anything like that
though that definitely didn't entice me
so like I said I've holed my wallet I
don't even see the value I didn't pick
up and dramatis so again I wait for it
to come to EA access for free I don't
see the value in a single player DLC I
see it inside an MMO stuff like destiny
and stuff like that I see the value
there the value in a close game once you
finish these games the hot like like
Lord Sovereign said unless there's a
loop factor going back to doing this
thing there's no sense for you to go
back into this world to replay and
retrace your steps all the way over it
doesn't make any sense I don't see the
validity and
and I don't think it's viable in yeah I
think it's dying out looking let me ask
you a quick question before we get the
bug Lords in what about like a like a
world that you just fall in love with
like there's no gaining that like you
just really fell in love with that world
back I know it to your point you said
you're not you're not buying this DLC
even what was explained to me all unless
the message in was poor in a trial based
type of things I like you hit a dungeon
in it right right this first one is more
yeah master trials is not anything
story-driven like exactly doesn't add
anything to the law it doesn't add
anything to the story
it doesn't enhance the gameplay from a
standpoint that I get in the game
there's a section of the world that's
opened up to me that I didn't see no
heart to is gonna do something more
along that line now what's that interest
you
yes okay so as your thing is more
narrative based like if you play
experience and it was narrative based
from the beginning okay then the DLC
should go in that same vein like you
should be a new world to open up like if
is Andromeda the DLC should have been
oh this section of the universe was
closed to you and it's a story arc that
you went over here like before they did
that remember they dropped all 4 DLC
before and we hadn't went to different
spots in different worlds so it doesn't
make any sense if it's DLC for
single-player game and they wanna
isolate you in a womb until you are the
bosses as hard as happy not about that
bad about Zelda to speak to his point
for a second it just I feel Zelda
actually has less of that single-player
stuff and to me the most Delta to me
feels more like that living like like
that living world even though it is a
single-player game together I returned
to Zelda for the advancement make they
made in the gameplay systems they like
let they let you play with in Zelda in
terms of life you know the the stasis
and all that stuff right so to me that's
more true
so to me that's more intriguing to go
back to so I kind of think that's why
that VLC sort of works for me because
it's just giving you more opportunities
to play around with the systems that the
game is created you know as opposed to
just throwing some story stuff on
obviously the story stuff is coming
later and I'm sure they'll let you play
with the system's also but to me like
Zelda kind of works in that regard where
it feels kind of like a destiny or
something like that in that they just
want you to play around in that world
and give more of that stuff with the
medallion the map traveling writings and
open it up target look good zero I want
to get your feedback here it to me it
depends on the context of the DLC what
is gonna consist of so basically I
remember y'all know how much of like
tarsals right yes yeah when they first
announced the first DLC for Dark Souls 3
of the ashes of aerion though if they
kind of made it look like at first it
was gonna be mostly a PvP arena kind of
thing which I don't care for in Dark
Souls it's not I'm not about that so III
completely written it off and then later
on they showed that it was gonna include
like a whole new world and a new story
and everything and everything and like
that and then I was on board again so I
don't know it for me like I said oh come
with David on this one it depends on
what it consists of for a single-player
game if it's just expand the story
that's what I want that's what I want
I'm gonna need to be on board with it
okay this is a good one let's all jump
in unless dizzy Dizzy's back I'll get
dizzy as well yeah go ahead jump um I
mean the whole thing with a DLC like
right now I don't think that the it's
it's all about retention and if your
game doesn't have that kind of retention
your DLC is just gonna fail right if
it's a crappy game just because you
added what you think is cool DLC people
aren't gonna and for Nintendo here's the
thing with Nintendo and especially for
jumping in like it's something brand new
to them so DLC might be a little bit
more retentive especially with their
kind of franchises you know people are a
little bit more excited with their
franchises and they are for most other
franchises it's gonna work for a game
like Uncharted it's gonna work for a
game like got a war if 343 did it for
Halo I imagine it would hoppy would work
for Halo I'd buy it in RP it will do the
same for it and every day again so
there's a couple of things you're gonna
have to look at is it gonna have the
people if you're gonna do for
single-player is it gonna have the
people to have that kind of retention is
it marked at the right price point
because not all DLC is gonna be
equivalent you know look at it look at
what but that's to do with Skyrim they
did that hurt what was they called heart
stone or something like that yeah but it
was moderately priced they knew that it
wasn't like it wasn't something very
impactful then it had a lot of story
anyway it added new features and whatnot
and what they did is they they drew down
the price of it they're like you know
we're not gonna sell this if it's not at
the right price point cuz if they sold
it the same way that they sold the other
two or three they people weren't gonna
pick it up just to you know guild build
a house let you screw that I'll go get
the stamps you know at that point all of
that the thing with the you know into
Kings Point the thing with mmo's and
open worlds and things that are gonna
have a lot of people playing with it is
gonna have retention because everybody's
gonna be doing it
you know Blizzard probably has the best
outlet for their game with like Diablo 3
they just released a new DLC from a game
that came out back in like what 2012
2011
yes been awhile you know they just
dropped a new DLC years years later and
like I mean my girlfriend she's a big
Diablo 3 lover she hasn't played it in a
while and now this DLC dropped I just
got her morrowind for Elder Scrolls but
she wants it she wants to pick up this
necromancer
you'll see people going crazy so good
but they changed the way to fit that
loot scheme like King was talking about
so now it's a loot based game big-time
lube based game so they swap that out
they added things into there that will
kind of like change the dynamic of the
game of the way that the single-player
works you know because if it's just a
game that is based around that linear
story yeah it better be a damn good
story otherwise better so we're not
gonna be absolutely especially with that
you'll see I'm with you yeah you spoke
about the Uncharted and the god of War's
even Uncharted like if you think about
it some you've finished uncharted 4 and
I you know at that point I don't want to
see any uncharted for quite some time
finishing that so if you give me a dlc
two months later that has more Nathan
Drake I'm not gonna be too excited so
what you do is that you have whatever
deal see you have in the works with
different characters in that world and
in there you turn it into a solo
purchase you it becomes an extension of
that universe so now with Lost Legacy
it's a game unto itself it's in that
universe it's in that engine but it's
new it feels new right I feel you I mean
this is a good one I want to jump in
because you really I'm glad you brought
this up I saw because you got that the
gears grinding in the mind with this and
I had to check myself I think I'm like
an addict for single player DLC game in
history and I was just like I noticed if
there's a game I'm very passionate about
like I just don't care I'm gonna by the
way I really noticed me like I mean XCOM
is a good example right now I know they
um they had dropped I know they got the
expansion coming in in August with the
chosen stuff but um XCOM - I kind of
went dug up my backlog and I started
jumping in that and I realized since I
was born like they had some alien hunter
DLC they had some stuff and I just
sucked that stuff right up and it kind
of revitalize it to me now does every
game do it you know I do it for
know what and I do agree the Lord
Disney's point that you know it has to
be compelling content the retention rate
has to be high I just think that with me
if it's a game that loses me in the
world where I'm like completely believe
this universe I love it like a game like
Mass Effect I remember when Mass Effect
2 and 3 will play one off the shadow
Shadow Ball
I love that stuff so I mean maybe it's
just my consumerism but um I do miss it
I do miss you know that company's you
know when he do it
but I do see also Phil's point which is
getting back to you like the death of
single player game in general and how
they have to come up with new ways and
maybe you know now it's not as
profitable I think in in Zelda's case
it's one of those things - Lord Kings
Point where let's be honest there's not
a lot of games out right for the system
in general as a whole and you know
people are starving for content so maybe
for Nintendo's case you know it's a game
only device and this is one of their
biggest you know franchises that the
Zelda DLC works for them you know kind
of thing but um this is good so because
I love the practice I hope it doesn't do
away you know I see games like Witcher
which I still haven't touched it went
back log me every time I look it's like
blood wine I'm dreading touching going
back hitting ad in my back logs already
know that's a game I feel like that's
cut you off I feel like they did too
much for their own good released it all
the one times right right because I want
to go back and play it but the game is
intimidating and I don't know both you
like I look at it I'm like I'm too far
gone too far removed from it you know
that kind of thing but I understand what
you say it's a good one I mean I ideally
I would hope you know the practice does
continue free
Oh sir no no no when I purchased it I
must have purchased the big shebang boss
oh yeah you guys know the monks with it
stuff is in the store and it was like oh
install it so I I swear I thought it was
free so when you said purchase I was
like yeah if you bought the deluxe
edition it came with everything so
people assumed it was just you know
whatever additional DLC but when it came
out that each one of those DLCs is
essentially a game unto itself
that's how big they are like people
really excited because it's like really
you're giving us all this content yeah
yeah it is a very intimidating game
especially if you stop doing getting
back into the flow of the game that's
that's what I got on it if any of the
laws got any more talk about
single-player before we move I'm just
I'm with you on this I hope it doesn't
stop but I honestly see it happening sir
yeah unfortunately I feel like it's
gonna be sooner I hope they start
packaging it differently and just you
know whatever they take a year take a
year and give me something in that world
not necessarily with those main
characters may give me a compelling
reason to go back right that world
because I mean when you like GTA 5 not
not giving that single player DLC that
they had initially promised when they
sparked when rockstar starts look in
different ways then you have to start
looking at you know where where the
industry is going because right you know
they're so big so you know until your
point this is what Phil's been talking
about right like this is it's kind of
like he's been talking about is the
death to the single flip but and it's
not I got to stop saying that because
then it's a narrative that we were
running with that he didn't really say
um you know like his basic thing is the
development dollars isn't there for the
closed-off space man he's seen the
development dollars is being shown like
like Lord does he say it's going in a
different Avenue in the Avenue is the
reoccurring dollar as far as people
playing so I understood that what he was
saying it wasn't like he was cutting
this all
but what he's seeing is that is no
return on investment when it comes to a
similar play a game unless the single
play a game as a smash yeah right that's
exactly what I don't misquote him on
that we got really out of control to the
point where I'm like the man forces him
not to say things because it's always
taken and twisted and took my lord out
here in a chat the winter so DS
enhancement dude good point like games
like gears were for quantum break like
he really wish they had story DLCs and I
you know gift for has been pretty much
all multiplayer and quantum break needed
to give both wildest old it stories from
closure so I agreed him in a standpoint
because like like Lord 0 saying it's
like for some games that you really
passion on and you have great world you
would like instead of it just being all
multiplayer yes next to robot that we
haven't checked about the original like
the Mass Effect Andromeda think that's a
game they could have benefited from
excellent DLC lifting up lifting up the
generally beneficial like I'm gonna be
really chewed like I cooled off and I'm
a little bit it's not that the game was
terrible you just I was a lot of stuff
is going on and as he think he start to
get better but like my thing is you
could have got me back if they bow where
they'd be like y'all we got the quarians
you know I'm saying oh you know almost
my main thing what's his race to travels
the drill I'm saying they play you're
ldl-c we found the pod that the thing
where they act with what you called the
ark where they add or whatever and I'm
saying it just said like because of
what's happened you know now we can't
all kind of hoping everyone was truce
off like when you when you broke that
down it's not true that's a whole
if I would do well I'm not gonna swallow
anything know the ending the ending has
left so open-ended to that DLC would
have benefited it even more especially
that game with its history right like my
do not buy and wait we've got a lot of
things from looking at the Xbox one X
benchmark the talk went around team what
you got okay so I'm gonna end on a high
note with the benchmarks I want to just
a general statement do you guys notice
that anytime Xbox has an exclusive game
or game that's ambiguous when it comes
to exclusivity that play Satan wants to
attach their name to it like is a
fantastic game it looks marvelous it
plays like like butter like a dream
beyond style the game is finally coming
we finally got a release date it's
finally almost hey we got to wait till
September I mean I'm chomping at the bit
for this game and then I look on message
boards and it was like it's coming to
PlayStation 4 but it's not it's not the
blue I mean are y'all upset with this at
any time that we have any title I mean
the place that you don't hear we're
saying god of war come
[Music]
you know days gone and say oh yeah days
God is on xbox they always want to
either test a name to a game or try to
take the luster away from exclusive
rollout or or do what they do best
still our footage and claim it was bad
Photoshop on top of stuff it's just like
when is enough enough like when I've
never seen somebody winning so paranoid
is so afraid of the resort to these type
of ridiculous tactics and this is this
not coincidence what a jump in against
the majority but the lower to your xbox
is our perfect platform right and the
only thing I will say that I really went
thousand agree with Lord King is that
you know when you look at stuff like the
rise of the Tomb Raider Fiasco you know
I'm saying and people were crying from
the heavens that this is you know unjust
and this is not fair to the PlayStation
community and I'm of the mindset that
you know exclusives are part of the game
whether we like it or not that is what
drives onto someone's platform so if
someone put the money down regardless of
how I feel about it they deserve the
right to have that exclusivity right so
when you hear it I just do it real
looking from the standpoint
that playstation is the market leader
right there dominating in the sales
they're winning you know they have the
the install base but I noticed a lot of
the community hug games but they get in
their feelings if something is confirmed
as an Xbox exclusive yes and then all of
a sudden you hear the soap boxes of why
is this not coming to PlayStation this
is not well meanwhile I didn't hear a
peep from anyone which three five two
five was announced for la station Xbox I
didn't see the petitions I didn't see
you know I mean just that same fervor
and energy when the exclusivity falls on
that side you know me because they're
the market that's the part of the game I
don't like you know saying it's just
like 4k 60 frames per second who made
the game said when it was first
announced that it was never never coming
to PlayStation so where did this come
from that was years ago now that we have
an official release date it's coming I
mean you know it's look it's just like
anything else I mean I mean I'm exposed
I see stuff like horizon I see certain
stuff that I'm just like really good but
if I run it and go out there and pick up
you know exactly you know I'm saying if
you want car page you need to go out you
need to pick up an Xbox
we're battlegrounds right wasn't that a
point of contention no it's it's
exclusive and like a year to back when I
have my playstation and I wanted
played blood-borne I didn't whine that
it wasn't coming the one I picked it up
on the goddamn PlayStation pick it up
and that's it that to me exclusives
drive the business is it anti-consumer i
guess you can say technically but that
helps what it helps a platform drive
business and uniqueness it makes you go
to that console you have this the only
game right now four places and I will
tell you when I get a release date for
it that really got me like oh is that
Detroit Detroit became I'm at the call
it my boy
you know Lord J Murrey and I'd the court
and the other game would be Shenmue
those are the only two games that
emotionally movie to the point okay
can't wait I gotta jump in to be honest
with you I really didn't even know that
that was the thing until I saw it coming
across my Twitter feed and I honestly I
think that there was a lot of
PlayStation guys didn't even know that
that was the thing mostly people to
responded in my Twitter they're like
yeah I don't really know where this came
from
it's just weird
because it's just one of those weird
things like I mean I don't think it's
it's not a problem to be a fanboy but
it's a problem to be a fanatic and I
think that there's there's an issue
there there's there should be a
separation like I know the fanboy gets
tossed around there's like the the
acronym that everybody uses to call each
other let's separate that fanboy fanatic
there are four Nanak's out there and
they will say anything it's just like
every single time that a Halo game drops
within a month or two this is gonna be
coming to PlayStation oh my god you
gotta be so true so true so true to your
point not to cut you know that's a great
point because remember the whole
narrative in the beginning well it's not
a really exclusive because it's on PC
and at that time there's nothing another
PlayStation you know be on PC but as we
here now with PS now being announced and
we're seeing he has four titles which is
telling your PC's
it's funny how the narrative oh yeah
it's always to fit your own narrative in
the second that your narrative works
against you use like I don't know what
you're talking about there's nothing
more that I could say to me it's just
it's at awkward its we go soft you get
that you get when you're winning you
feel like you know again if if this is
true that the developer said that it was
exclusive years ago then maybe nobody
jumped at anything because years ago
there was more parity in terms of
PlayStation and Xbox so you know now you
know four or five years you know four
years removed from that PlayStation has
a considerable lead so the people who
are quote unquote fanatics of bamboo is
they they feel everything needs to come
to them period but it is sort of weird
because this game in particular more so
than and then other like graphically
intensive games this is a game that is
on PC like again the argument was made
before that you know what all you need
the argument against Xbox that you know
you don't need an Xbox all you need is a
DC PC and a ps4 and your cover well then
this this is a game that can run
probably on the most middle Linux
systems like so honestly it's gonna get
to a vast majority of people who follow
that narrative and have a ps4 probably
have a PC should be able to play this
game without too much of a problem so I
don't again it's a weird argument to
make and it just comes from entitlement
and it's you know it's it's annoying to
listen to to be honest
absolutely now locate you had a couple
other things you want to jump in now yes
the next thing is the overwatch I just
wanted I want to get this out there my
biggest problem with all this stuff to
have is with the exclusives and
everything I want to put it out there I
don't care so much for the fans saying
what the fans do because look if you
like a sport like I used to watch
wrestling all the goddamn time during
Attitude Era
mm-hmm and even when like Stone Cold
Francis was the bad guy right he was the
bad guy our root for him because he was
[ __ ] cool right no that was that was
your dude you back to LA when you
watched it and everything you're like
that move your sports teams right my
biggest issue with all this stuff going
on is the absolute competence of the
media and the hypersensitivity that
everybody has nowadays that's my biggest
issue because you can tell sometimes
will you read articles or watch videos
about things people just don't do the
goddamn research anymore nowadays it's
because all this stuff this same stuff
happened last year like Xbox people
complained when a PlayStation exclusive
didn't come the Xbox last year because
they felt entitled just like Laura
Johnson but the thing is it's out in the
forefront more nowadays because you know
the media is making it that wet that way
and people are more sensitive this stuff
nowadays and that's not Justin you know
gaming media or anything that's just in
general you know feel like that's the
biggest problem now because fans are
gonna be fans that's you're a fan that's
what you do what's a good point Minh
definitely a piggyback know what
everybody said so what can you said the
next one was overwatch I don't know if
anybody's been keeping up with the
characters of overwatch but it's a long
time now like from actually the release
of the game they were talking about
doofus now he's the reference in the
game the fist has been taken out of the
case and he's supposed to be coming and
for a long time Terry Crews voice has
been linked to it and background
discussions Terry Crews has been part of
the whole narrative of doom fist so it
was automatically assumed that when doom
fizzes ever showed up eventually because
he was going to show up that because he
was working on the character balance and
the character and stuff like that the
Terry Crews will voice the character now
to people shock and dismay
the character came out and when he spoke
it wasn't Terry Crews so the
to people shock and dismay an xbox III
show when this show crack down we was
like why is Terry Crews here and he's
the voice of the main agent in the game
and he had a whole big commercial for
him I mean the commercials that's
running for crackdown is Terry Crews
basically bring the boom yeah boom let
your boom speak whatever the hell it is
Cruz
screw herself out of doom fist or did
they just bump him out because if the
money wasn't there to make him doing
viscera and he went over to crackdown or
what you said it was a bait and switch
my friend going to be the voice I don't
think that NAT wall I think you know
what I didn't jump on initial bandwagon
because remember it was on overwatch and
it was another game that came out at the
same time it was the same ilk and that
other game I forgot the name of it and
I'm not doing any justice and I do
apologize and commander somebody else
thank you the battle woman all right um
those two games came out neck-and-neck
it's like if you release two fighting
games at one time you wanna make a
choice right and okay Blizzard one
obviously take the overwatch became the
thing now by the time
the thing I was I wasn't playing you
know if you jump on right now these guys
take you up so they already know they
combo they're ready know who you know if
you're running with a team who's
supposed so really I'm at a disadvantage
so I said okay well when game fish comes
out because I like Terry Crews Assad
jump I'll be going first and then people
will be learning doing fists and I can
learn
I was so dismayed it wasn't doing fost
that I didn't purchase never thought
that was gonna happen though because you
don't play overwatch to hear the
characters talk correctly from wrong
goal especially Inc there because I know
he's gonna be in the chat but the other
characters they don't have any like big
noteworthy voice actors do they know it
seemed like a weird anomaly to me and it
just didn't make sense for that to
happen it could be just like what you're
saying I mean it definitely could be a
lobbying switch tactic generate hype for
the character and you know ultimately
the good thing is at least Terry's able
to land on his feet cuz it seem like
he's our core gamer like he's really
involved with this stuff you know he
said gaming to connect with his son and
you know I was to be honest I mean I was
happy that caught the king they blew the
budget but now you get emotionally
invested because something about that
game I'm just not emotionally yeah I
felt was big you know saying okay Terry
he's get you you know do the missions
yadda yadda and yeah I mean this voice
acting games tough out here man real
quick I want to jump well your first
look like I did
we talked over the benchmarks right yeah
do you want to talk about it good man
they look good from what I've seen I
mean to me the biggest announcement for
me personally I was saving that for last
digital foundry recently released that
the white paper and the white paper that
they weren't able to talk about before
it was basically a broad spectrum of I
think was like ten games that they took
open world of racing and they didn't
give you the names of the games but they
gave you the benchmarks of the games and
it showed how they work in actual real
environments on the old X decays or XT
X's now that they're called for the Xbox
one and they showed how the game
performed using the Xbox of One X and in
that environment and what was the games
and what was the pitfalls in said games
and it showed games across the bullets
on all of the games and that wasn't even
optimized to the X DX a--'s for the Xbox
ones and my thing is being it wasn't
optimized yet and they showed complete
games across the board that it was
blowing it out the water
what was your views on it how did you
feel about it did anybody see the white
papers and the jealous into digital
foundries when they was telling you that
it was like 60% of usage of utilization
without optimization and what's gonna
come when we actually get these products
this product in our household when the
games are optimized for it because they
were current gen titles that were
triple-a titles yeah definitely um I
think what would it speaks to is the the
ease of porting these games over to the
X and the fact that I think Microsoft is
gonna do everything in their power to
make sure that they did they optimize
all of these canyons and
and I'm talking about not necessarily
old obviously the first-person stuff
they're gonna make sure that they
optimize these games to the fullest to
make sure that they get every ounce of
power they can out of that ex with with
existing games I also think they're
gonna go out of their way to help third
parties make sure that their games are
optimized even if the third party
doesn't want to invest the money into it
I think with with with their performance
analyzer and I and I think with the
hands-on that they've exhibited that
they're willing to go with the in terms
of the ex I just think that they're not
gonna allow a game to move to the system
unoptimized even if the developer
developer themselves doesn't want to
invest in it or they think it's it's
it's not worth the investment for the
improvement they're gonna get I think
Microsoft is gonna pick up that slack
because that to me if you look at
arguments that people are having now
about you know why I'm great to the X
what's the big difference I think
Microsoft hears that and they they
realize that they really need to step up
on their and to make sure that those
differences are seen so just speaking to
what you see like raw numbers yeah I
mean obviously it's very impressive and
I again Richard Ledbetter made it made
it clear that these are not in-game
optimizations this is not right it's not
what do you mean that it's not gameplay
optimizations that they're not in a
gameplay environment it's just like
standard standard tech tech tech moving
tech over so obviously those numbers are
gonna skew differently once you get all
the systems within the game running but
that said the amount of overhead left
once it's moved to the Xbox 1x is
impressive it's impressive because you
know that there's so much more you can
do with it so I think Microsoft's gonna
do everything their power to make sure
that every single game is as optimized
as it possibly can be will it be a slow
process yeah maybe um but I think I
think they have no choice but to do that
to convince people why the X is worth
the purchase so right I don't know did
you get a chance to catch any that a
Richard a little bit honest you know
since e3 I really haven't cared too much
about the men
marks I'm excited for the the 1x when it
comes out I want to see you know happen
out in front of me I see you I said so
then everything is all speculation and
just hearsay so until we see the working
of love us
oh yeah that that's just my standpoint
on it it any excitement real quick dizzy
any excitement about the recent
announcement of Halo 5 getting the
treatment getting the ex treatment no I
didn't like give me any incentive to go
back and play it and everything just
because it looks great
I mean I've I've always said they're
like I mean it's if it looks pretty cool
but it has to be compelling enough like
I'm sorry like I haven't felt that
compelled to go back and play another
Halo since Halo Reach
so obviously but we won't be complaining
about that I think the fun of it is just
like just going to you like week like we
spoke about a couple weeks ago the fact
that you know anything you have on Steam
when you get a new computer with a new
GPU in mind is going to go back and see
how you like which is no problem which
because I'm literally holding back on
playing games for right now to campaign
like there's a couple of games I'm
sitting on my nope I know that's gonna
get to treatment 500 game pile of shame
500 games polishing the backlog good I'm
excited back and see what what
and shout out the Lord zero Lord loss
often part of that chaos 8000 yeah I
know looking he's stepping it up on us
you know what oh oh oh LED status but oh
just eat his stuff you know and and
finally max my TV in true native in to
see what that's about
so again for a person like me like but
give me games that actually run
checkable you know what if all your
games okay I'm done with it but you know
you know there's a lot of games that
come out they're just not it not 4k
right yeah for no reason is gonna come
across and be viable for your new
purchased we had a lot to talk about
though it's an away from it but of
anybody else got anything to say before
we wrap this thing up we have time it's
just a short one there I wanted a pinion
on when you buy a game they includes a
season pass how long did you how long is
acceptable wait until you see that DLC
almost that is including the Nessie's
investment
mmm this is good questions so they say
you buy a season pass for a game and you
see
how long right is it get acceptable
like give me examples wait because
here's the thing and here's where I come
from and it's not gonna anybody's neck I
promise no I know this it might be
sensitive some people but I bought the
full game a season pass for both
injustice and Tekken right and I have
seen none of the DLC from Tekken yet
okay I'm not okay with that because
injustice
tomorrow night is their second character
already mmm and I haven't seen it like I
said I haven't seen anything they just
announced Tekken Bowl even that you have
to pay separately are you saying there
might be included in the season pass
okay say oh boy even if it's if it's in
this user patch and you don't have it
you still have to pay for it okay I got
a killer stemming I got anything my
thought process on it and I know anger
man I can feel this is when you
announced the season pass I need to have
an outline of what you think you are
going to provide I cannot go I mean this
time listen check it I fell victim to it
I'm a Tekken nut I bought it without
question that's my own fault I'm the
victim of whatever every that happens
these characters game modes and all they
gave you a blueprint but the thing is
you purchased the game the game came out
and they have said a word about it yet
right and again it still was the kind of
let's be I'm not even call a spade a
spade it still was kind of a murky
blueprint right it was kind of like
right yeah we gonna give you some
characters you know you know we're gonna
like there was no definitive thing like
I like with games like it just actually
get you know I give credit like you know
shout out the mark in the division like
at least you know it was like okay you
gonna get this then you gonna give the
final stand and you gonna get whatever
he's give me a name a template a
placeholder right so then when and you
don't even I don't even gotta be mad I
give you the date you can say spring you
can say fall you know I'm saying I'm
cool with that just so I got an idea
okay that's calm
but when it's like yo trust us don't
take it this way I'm not with the yo you
know how we do you know just buy it you
go see I never bought the season pass
for Fallout when I didn't do it we own
all principle alone it if I want to just
what the regular game now I wasn't a
minor because you got you guys when they
put the gun in the head and said
tomorrow it'll be $60 of you what are
the rest of Lots feeling it's a good one
it depends on how long how long I'm
willing to stay engaged in that world so
all right look for a fighting game
definitely I want those characters as
soon as possible I mean look if you look
at what chief i-25 did like they were
handing them out piecemeal like one
every six months or something like that
was just ridiculous so the again it's a
matter of it's about how willing I am to
come back to that world
I agree that I need an outline and I did
the same thing as the king there with
the guns in the head with the way to do
that was the best
they were gonna go there I said no [ __ ]
this game already heavily invested and I
was on the fence and that's a great
pushing into the water or pull them over
the fence and I just had to jump into
that water because they said tomorrow is
going to be double I will rather mess up
cheaply they mess up we've gone over a
little bit coming
hoji status like that was bumpy but at
you know Sam but I've gotta give a
shout-out to of course on me Lord dizzy
playback gaming in these streets what
you look forward to talk to me well
thank you thank you once again for
having me over here it's uh an awesome
thing to be an honorary Lord and it
sounds like I got a little Lord over
here that wants to speak the guilty yeah
you can also catch me over on Planet
Xbox with a kid smooth that's every
Tuesday night sir we've been doing that
for probably about a month maybe a month
and a half now a really fun time and
everything we actually have a new rider
or a newer writer if anybody seen Panda
oh we don't pandas and Amanda she's a
she's a constant rider over here at
playback gaming and everything so she
has a lot of great content making a lot
of friends over in the indie developer
she's also as I have a nerdy queen yes
yes like Nicodemus likes to call himself
the king of Indies she would be the
queen of Indies yes so yes you'll be
able to catch us both over there on
Planet Xbox this Wednesday we do have
another after-hours podcast I know it's
been a little while but we will be
coming back with that talking about more
topics of about the whole nerdy section
of life but yeah tune in you can follow
me over at twitter @ idat 1 so you can
try to follow me on xbox I may add you
back
I'm very secretive I have to be as an
art gamer I understand you can also be
sure to go check out our playback gaming
net some of the unknown gaming news
you'll see you no doubt know much
appreciated for coming through this is
long overdue
you know playback has helped I love
pockets of so many ways there's a
platform
I always appreciate you bro and I look
forward to seeing what you guys got
cooking up and shout out that like you
said lady pan though she's killing it
right now queen of England's zero
articles everybody that's you know
saying I really respect that and huh
yeah the roundtable we're gonna close
this out so um Lord stuff working the
fun people
box live at the XR n PS nbx sovereign
one word and on Twitter Lord style my
OPP and of course exs game by himself
look you already know where I'm at on
those platforms like say a shout out to
Lords what the mobile and everything
Church
should be in a minute
after the plane propeller stuff gold
alright so anyway the the t-shirts and
logos and stuff is up so we'll have the
t-shirts ready hats cups and the trucker
purse is to show you how I earn Lord's
love and it would be greatly appreciated
so whenever you out at these functions
we know that you download our podcast
doubt the Lord's zero I know you've been
working me but we can you're not in
kindly don't like Lord zero IOP you
finally change that gamertag that's
enough know you can find me on Twitter
at Lord zero make sure to follow
playback game I mean later today or
tomorrow I should have an article while
talking about the games coming to ESL
they just recently announced that Dragon
Ball xenoverse 2 is gonna be featured as
well as drag all fighters and adjust
this so I'm gonna do it right up on that
if anybody's out no doubt of course it
is low cockney you know here we give you
that gaming realness every week we
appreciate the support that likes all
that good stuff I want to shout out Lord
sinister because um he's been out needs
a Twitter and I mean twitching mixer
streets he's been he's been streaming
hard y'all please support channel I
believe you sinister x2 on on Twitter
twitch and on mixer we're gonna be doing
a lot of that a lot of CO stream use is
kind of a prep before destiny too so
he's on that check him out check his
Twitter out really does good content
over then we're gonna be getting that
bubbling and of course I got a shout out
the playback you know saying it's always
good to have the fam in the building
supporting the molecular stuff and of
course lurker yeah I'm more Cognito now
on Xbox Live no longer just Cognito
there so it's Lord on shout out there um
Winter Soldier Chat Chat was lit y'all I
want a shout out to chat today Chad had
been rollin chat was live long been that
like button subscribe iTunes SoundCloud
you to all that good stuff man and I
wish they're the best podcast
you've never heard and one last shot I
want to give out a shout out salute to
the TX our podcast I know those guys
kind of loaf
Voltron Lions Broca let's just say that
but we respect all of them you know
infernal rain all these guys come on the
show and always shown support and yeah
man we're gonna miss you guys and like I
said hopefully you guys can move on to
the next endeavor whatever you do and
also support these iron Lords man we out
here you know that we gonna wrap this
thing up